the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
okay the other thing is so the last
lecture before the break and a bit
abruptly because I run out of time so
just to summarize what the main point
was I mean probably you figure this out
you know if you look at the notes it's
not that important but anyway just
wanted to remind you that you know just
to clarify what happened at the end we
got the diffusion equation from two bits
of information so we I mean the unknown
in this partial differential equation is
a function that we call you that
corresponds to the concentration of some
substance and we used a vector field
that represents the flow of whatever the
substance is whose diffusion we're
studying and well so we got two bits of
information what one that came from
physics let's say that the flow goes
from high concentration to small to
smaller concentration and that told us
that the flow is proportional to a
negative gradient of the concentration
and the second piece of information that
we got was from the divergence theorem
and that's the one which I spend time
trying to explain and that one told us
that the divergence of F is actually
negative partial U of a partial T so
when you combine these two relations
together that's how you get the
diffusion equation
sorry I should say this is not the
statement of a divergence theorem but
this is something that we derived from
it with quite a few steps involved and
so what we got out of that is the
diffusion equation because we end up
getting that partial u partial T is
minus del F which is therefore positive
K times divergence of grad U which is
what we denoted by del square U the
laplacian so that's how we got the
diffusion equation okay anyway I let you
know have a look at the notes that were
handed out in case you really want to
see more I just wanted to
give a missing part of the last lecture
okay so let me just switch gears
completely and switch to today's topic
which is actually line integrals and
work in 3d so that's going to look a lot
like what we did in the plane except of
course there's a Z coordinate but you'll
see it doesn't change things much when
it comes to computing a line integral it
changes things quite a bit
however when it comes to testing whether
a field is a gradient field so that's
where we have to be more careful so okay
let's start right away with line
integrals in space so let's say that we
have a vector field F with components
say P Q and R and we should think of it
maybe as representing a force and let's
say that we have a curve C in space then
the work done by the field will be the
line integral along c of F dot DL okay
so that's a familiar formula and what we
do with that formula is also familiar
except now of course we have a Z
coordinate so we're going to think of
vector D R as a space vector with
components DX dy and DZ so when we do
the dot product of F with dr that will
tell us that we have to integrate pdx
plus qdy plus rdz okay but it's still a
line integral so it's still going to
turn into a simple integral a single
integral when you plug in the correct
values so the method will be exactly the
same as in the plane namely we'll find
some way to parameterize our curve X
plus XY Z in terms of a single variable
and
then we'll integrate with respect to
that variable okay so the way that we
evaluate is by Kermit rising c + x +
x/y/z
DX dy DZ in terms of the parameter okay
so let's do an example just to convince
you that you actually know how to do
this artist you should know how to do
this so let's say that I give you the
vector field with components Y Z X Z and
X Y and let's say that we have a curve
given by x equals T cubed y equals T
squared Z equals T for T going from 0 to
1 so the way we will set up the line
integral for the work done will be well
sorry so before we actually set up the
line integral we need to know how we
will express everything in terms of T
and DT so XY and Z in terms of T are
given here we just need to do also DX dy
and DZ well by differentiating you get
DX is 3t squared DT that's the
derivative of T cubed dy will be 2t DT
and DZ will just be DT and so
we'll evaluate the line integral for
work well that will be the integral of Y
Z DX plus XZ dy plus XY DZ which will
become so Y Z is T cubed times DX is 3 T
squared DT plus XZ is T to the 4 times
dy is 2t DT plus XY is T to the 5 DT ok
so it just becomes the integral from
well I guess T goes from 0 to 1 actually
and we are integrating 3 plus 2 plus 1
that's 6 T to the 5 DT which I'm sure
you know integrates to 3 to the 6 so
we'll just get 1 okay so it's the same
method as usual and if you're being
given this geometric description of a
curve then of course you have to decide
for yourself what the best parameter
will be it might be some time parameter
T like here it might be one of the
coordinates actually here we could have
used Z as a parameter it because in fact
this curve is x equals Z cubed and y
equals Z squared and we could also have
used maybe some angle well not here but
if we had been moving say in a circle or
something like that okay any questions
so far
nope
okay
so well because you know we can do a bit
more practice let's do another one where
we do the same vector field F but our
key of C will be going from the origin
to the point one zero zero along the x
axis so let's call that C 1 then 2 1 1 0
let's call that C 2 by moving parallel
to the y-axis and then up to 1 1 1
parallel to the z axis let's call that C
3 okay I'm sure that some of you at
least are suspecting what I'm getting at
here but let's not spoil it for those
who don't see it yet
ok so if we want to compute the line
integral along this guy this guy then we
have to actually break it into a sum of
three terms okay so while so maybe I
should call that C Prime let's see
because it's not the same C anymore so I
want to do the sum of the line integrals
along c1 c2 and c3 and well if I look at
c1 OHC 2 actually so c1 and c2 take
place inside the xy-plane
so in fact you know that Z will be zero
and DZ will also be zero and both of
these and if you just look at you know
the formula for line integral integral
of Y Z DX plus XZ dy plus XY DZ well it
looks like if you plug Z equals 0 and D
is equal to zero it will just get zero
so this actually very fast well
naturally fine well okay let me write it
all right so this is going to be zero
this is going to be zero this is going
to be zero and we'll get zero okay now
if we do C 3 well we might have to
actually do a calculation but it won't
be all that bad so C 3 well x and y are
both equal to 1 and of course because
they are constant that means DX is 0 dy
is 0 and on the other hand Z varies from
0 to 1 so if I look at the line integral
on C frame well so the first two terms Y
Z DX and XZ dy go away because DX and dy
are 0 so I'm just left with X Y DZ but
because x and y are 1 that's just the
integral of DZ from 0 to 1 and that will
just end up being 1 ok so if I add these
numbers together 0 plus 0 plus 1
I get one again and of course it's not a
coincidence because this vector field
actually is a gradient field I'm sure
some of you have already figured out
what it's the gradient of otherwise
we'll figure it out together and so
that's why actually we get the same
answer for these two paths going both
from the origin to 1 1 1 I mean maybe I
should point out to make it clearer if
you plug T equals 0 in the path up there
you'll get zero zero zero if you plug T
equals 1 you'll get 1 1 1 so in fact
this vector field effort we have here
happens to be conservative and if you
plot the two curves together so well I'm
not very sure if I know how to cut this
quietly but I believe that you know
somehow well it's not exactly how it
looks something okay whatever so the
first curve C goes from the origin to
this point and so the C prime just in a
slightly more roundabout way so you know
they both go from the origin to one one
one so it's not a surprise that you'll
get the same answer for both line
integrals and how do we see that well
actually here it's not very hard to find
a function whose gradient is this vector
field namely well the gradient of XYZ
looks like it should be exactly what we
want right if you take partial of this
with respect to X you'll get Y Z then
respect to Y X Z and with respect to Z X
Y and so in fact what was the easier way
to compute these nine integrals
well that was to use the fundamental
theorem of calculus we didn't actually
you know once we have this remark we
don't need to compute this line
integrals anymore we can just use the
fundamental theorem
so if we know this the fundamental
theorem
well cough calculus for line integrals
blah blah blah for nine integrals so
that tells us that the line integral of
a gradient field is equal to the value
of the potential at the final point
minus the value of a potential at the
starting point okay and that of course
only applies if you have a potential so
in particular only if you have a
conservative field a gradient field okay
so here in our particular example well
so we have to look at
let's call little F of XYZ that
potential XYZ then we take F of 1 1 1
minus F of 0 0 0 and that indeed is 1
minus 0 which is 1
so everything is consistent ok so all
this stuff so far works exactly as
invoking any questions
nope okay so let's try to see where
things do get a little bit different and
the first such place is when we try to
test whether a vector field is a
gradient field so remember when we had a
function of two variables sorry when you
had a vector field in the plane to know
whether it was a gradient of a function
of two variables we just had to check
one condition and sub X equals M sub M
sub y now we'll actually have three
different conditions to check and that
means of course my work
okay
so okay so what's our test for gradient
fields so we want to know whether a
given vector field with components P Q
and R whether it can be written as f sub
X F sub y and F sub Z for the same
function f and for that to possibly
happen well we need certainly some
relations between P Q and R and as
before this comes from the fact that the
mixed second derivatives are the same no
matter in which order you take them so
if that's the case then I can compute F
sub XY which is the same as F sub YX in
two different ways right F sub XY should
be P sub y F sub YX well since F sub y
is Q which would be Q sub X ok so if you
want that's the part of a criterion that
we already had when we had only two
variables but now of course we need to
do the same thing when we look at X and
Z or Y & Z so that gives us two more
conditions so P sub Z is f sub X Z which
is the same as F sub Z X so it should be
the same as R sub X
and finally q sub Z which is f sub y Z
equals F sub Z y equals R sub y ok so we
have actually three conditions so our
criterion so a vector field F equals P Q
R and here to be you know completely
truthful I have to say defined in a
simply connected region otherwise we
might have the same kind of strange
things happening as before so we let's
not worry too much about it but just you
know so accuracy
we need our vector field to be defined
in a simply connected region and that
means for example well an example is
just if it's defined everywhere you know
if you don't have any evil denominators
then you can just you know go ahead
there's no problem is a gradient field
exactly when so we need three conditions
we need P sub Z well let's do it
nada let's P sub y equals Q sub X and we
have P sub Z equals R sub X and Q sub Z
equals R sub y so now how do you
remember these three conditions well
it's pretty easy you pick any two
components okay say the X and the Z
component and you take the partial of
the X component with respect to Z the
partial of the Z component with respect
to X and you must make them equal and
same with every pair of variables in
fact if you had a function of many more
variables the criterion would still look
exactly like that for every pair of
components the mixed partials must be
the
but we are not going to go beyond three
variables so you don't need to know that
this you need to know okay so let me box
it okay so well
[Music]
that's pretty straightforward let's do
an example just to see how it goes oh by
the way sigh you know we can also think
of it in terms of differentials okay so
we can say be Phi 2 the example let me
just say in a different language if we
have a differential given to us over
from pdx plus qdy plus rdz is going to
be an exact differential which means
it's equal to DF for some function f
exactly and of the same conditions if
it's the same thing just in the language
of differentials okay so the example
that I promised because I could do again
the same one over there and check that
it satisfies the condition but then you
know wouldn't be much fun so let's do a
better one so actually let's do it in a
way that looks like an exam problem
let's say for which a and B is a XY DX
plus it's not going to fit here
it will fit here a X Y DX plus x squared
plus Z cubed dy plus B Y Z squared minus
4z cubed DZ and exact differential if
you don't like exact differentials for
which a and B is the corresponding
vector field with you know I J and K
instead a gradient field so let's just
apply the criterion and of course you
can guess that what will follow will be
figuring out how to find the potential
when there is one
[Applause]
okay well so let's do it you know one by
one so we want to compare P sub y with Q
sub X we want to compare P sub Z with r
sub X and we want to compare Q sub Z
with our subway okay where we call P Q
and R these guys so let's see what is P
sub y that seems to be a X and what is Q
sub X 2x okay Q is this one actually let
me write them down because otherwise I'm
going to get confused myself so this guy
here that's P this guy here that's Q and
then guy here that are so okay so this
one tells us that a would be equal to 2
for the first purpose it will hold okay
let's look at P sub Z that's just 0
sub X well our doesn't have any X either
so that's 0 so this one isn't a problem
Q sub Z well that seems to be crazy
squared R sub y seems to be DZ squared
so B should be equal to 3
okay so we need to have equals two and
this is an end this is not all B equals
three for this to be exact
okay so for those values of a and B we
can look for potential using the method
but we are going to see right now for
any other values of a and B we can't if
we have to compute the line integral we
have to do it by finding the parameter
and setting up everything okay any
questions at this point yes if Q so if Q
Z was OAC what if I got the same answer
if I also got you know like did you say
DZ squared of ABCs well free/busy
squared for example then I would need B
to be 0 because the only times that
free/busy squared equals busy squared as
you know not just at one point but every
where I need them to be the same
function of XYZ well that would be if a
coefficient of Z square is the same that
would give me B equals 3 B that would
give me B equals 0 if you got busy
squared on both sides then it would mean
you know for any value of B it works and
you wouldn't have to worry about what
the value of B is ok any other questions
No
okay so now how do we find the potential
well there's two methods as before okay
so one of them I don't remember if it
was the first one or the second one last
time but it really doesn't matter one of
them was just to say that the value of F
at a point let me call that x1 y1 z1 is
equal to the line integral of my field
along a well-chosen curve class of
course a constant which is going to be
the integration constant and the kind of
curve that I will take to do this
calculation will just be my favorite
curve going from the origin to the point
x1 y1 z1 and so typically it would be
you know the most common choice would be
to go just first along the x-axis then
parallel to the y-axis and then parallel
to the z axis all the way to my point x1
y1 z1 so I would just calculate three
easy line integrals add them together
and that would give me the value of my
function okay so that's that method
works exactly the same way as it did in
two variables now I seem to recall that
you guys mostly prefer the other method
so I'm going to tell you about the other
method as well but I just want point out
this one actually it doesn't become more
complicated the other one there's
actually more steps and of course here
is also actually with more steps because
you have three parts to your path
instead of two so you have three line
integrals to compute instead of two but
conceptually it remains exactly the same
idea
so I should say it works the same way as
in 2d that much changes okay so let's
look at the other method using
anti-derivatives so remember we want to
solve we want to find a function little
F whose partials are exactly the things
we've been given so we want to solve
well let me plug in the values of a and
B that will work okay so we say the a
should be 2 so f sub X should be 2xy f
sub y should be x squared plus Z cubed
and F sub Z should be B was face so that
was say Y Z squared minus 4 Z cubed so
we're going to look at them one at a
time and get partial information on the
function and then we will compare with
the others to get more information until
we are completely done okay so the first
thing that we'll do we know that f sub X
is 2xy that should tell us something
about F well let's just integrate that
with respect to X so let me write
integral DX next to that so that tells
us that F should be well if we integrate
that respect to X to X integrates to x
squared so we should get x squared y
plus of course an integration constant
now what do we mean by an integration
constant well it means that actually for
given values of y and z will get a term
that does not depend on X it still
depends on y and z so in fact what we
get is a function of y and z see if you
took the derivative of this with respect
to X you'll get 2xy and this guy will go
away because there's no X in it okay so
that's the first step now we need to get
some information on G how do we do that
well we look at the other purfles so AB
sub y we want that to be x squared plus
Z cubed but actually we have another way
to find it which is starting from this
and differentiating to let me use let me
try to use color for this so so now if I
take the partial of this with respect to
Y I'm going to get a different formula
for F sub y that will be x squared plus
G sub y well if I compare these two
expressions that tells me that G sub y
should be Z cubed so now if I have this
well I can integrate with respect to Y
and that will tell me that G is actually
Y Z cubed plus an integration constant
that constant again does not depend on Y
but it can still depend on Z alright
because we still haven't said anything
about partial respect to Z so in fact
that constant I will write as a function
H of Z if I have this function of Z I
take its partial I will respect to Y I
will still get Z cubed no matter what
age was now how do I find H well
obviously I have to look at F sub Z
okay so f sub Z well we know from the
given vector field that we want it to be
three Y Z squared minus four Z cubed so
in case you're wondering where that came
from that was ah okay but that's also
obtained by differentiating with respect
to Z what we had so far
sorry so what did we have so far well we
had F equals x squared y plus G and we
say G is actually Y Z cubed plus h of Z
that's what we have so far so if we take
the derivative of that with respect to Z
we'll get well 0 plus y y is e squared
plus h prime of Z or DHT Z as you want
okay so now if we compare these two
we'll get the derivative of each it will
tell us that H prime is negative for Z
cubed and that means that H is negative
Z to the 4 plus a constant and this time
it's at last an actual constant because
it doesn't depend on Z and it has
nothing else for it to depend on so now
we plug this into what we had before and
that will give us our function f so we
get that f is x squared y plus y is e
cubed minus Z to the 4 plus constant if
you just wanted to find one potential
you can just forget the constant this
guy was the potential if you want all
the potentials they differ by this
constant ok so just to recap the method
what did we do we started with and of
course you can do it in whichever order
you prefer but you have to still you
know follow the systematic method so you
start with F sub X and you integrate
that with respect to X but gives you f
up to a function of Y & Z only now you
compare f sub y as given to you by the
vector field with the formula that you
get from this expression for F and that
of course this one will involve G sub y
so out of this you will get the value of
G sub y when you have G sub y that gives
you G up to a function of Z only and so
now you have F up to a function of Z
only and you what you will do is you
will look at the derivative respect to Z
well the one you want coming from the
vector field and the one you have coming
from this formula for F match them
that will tell you each time you will
get h and then you will get okay any
questions nope
okay who still prefers this method okay
that's still most of you who is thinking
that maybe the other method wasn't so
bad after all
okay that's still a minority well you
can choose whichever one you prefer I
would encourage you to you know get some
practice by trying both on at least a
couple of examples just to make sure
that you know how to do them both and
then you know stick to whichever one you
prefer okay any questions on that
nope I guess I already asked actually
well still no questions okay so the next
logical thing is going to be curl and
the theorem that is going to replace
greens theorem for work in this setting
that's going to be called Stokes theorem
so let me start by telling you about
curl in 3d
okay so here's the statement so the curl
actually is just going to measure how
much your vector field fails to be
conservative and if you want to think
about it in terms of motions but also
will measure the rotation part of the
motion so maybe I should say but let me
first give a definition anyway so let's
say that my vector field has components
P Q and R then we define the curl of F
to be R sub y minus Q sub Z times I plus
P sub Z minus R sub X times J plus Q sub
X minus P sub y times K and now of
course nobody can remember this formula
so what's the structure of this formula
where you see each of these guys is one
of the things that have to be 0 for our
field to be conservative so
by construction if F is defined in a
simply connected region then we have
that F is conservative is equivalent to
if and only if curl F is zero okay now
an important difference between curl
here and curl in the plane is that now
the curl of a vector field is again a
vector field
see these expressions they're functions
of XYZ and together you form a vector
out of them so the curl of a vector
field in space is actually a vector
field not a scalar function now okay so
I've delayed the inevitable I have to
really tell you how to remember this
evil formula so the secret is that in
fact you can think of this as del cross
F so maybe you've seen that in physics
so this is really where this Dell
notation becomes extremely useful
because that's basically the only way to
remember the formula for cow
so in fact so remember we introduced the
del operator that was the symbolic
vector operator in which the components
are the partial derivative operators so
we've seen well if you apply this to a
scalar function then that will give you
the gradient and we've seen that if you
do the dot product between del and the
vector field we they should give it
components P Q and R well when you do
the dot product between these two
vectors you'll get partial P partial X
plus partial Q partial y plus partial R
partial Z which is the divergence and so
now what's new
is that if I try to do del cross F okay
so what is del cross F so I have to set
up the cross-product between this
strange thing that is not really a
vector I mean I can't really think of
partial partial X as a number and my
vector field
PQR so see that's really a completely
perverted use of a determinant notation
okay
initially the terminals were just
supposed to be you had a three by three
table of numbers and you computed a
number out of them and now I mean okay
so these guys weld up function so you
know that countless numbers but these
are vectors and these are you know
partial derivatives it doesn't really
make much sense except this notation so
if you try to enter this into a
calculator or computer of interesting to
yell back at you saying are you crazy
and
and but okay so you know we just use
that as a notation to remember what's in
there so let's try and see how that
works so the component of I in this
cross-product
remember that's this smaller determinant
so that smaller determinant is partial
over partial Y of our minus partial
partial Z of kube that's the coefficient
of I and that seems to be what I had
over there if not when I made a mistake
- the next determinant times J remember
was always a minus sign in front of the
J component when you do a cross product
so the other one is partial partial X
minus partial partial Z of P plus the
component of Z is going to be partial
partial X Q minus partial partial Y P
and that's indeed going to be the curl
of F okay so in practice if you have to
compute the curl of a vector field you
know don't try to remember this formula
just set up this cross-product
with whatever formulas you have for the
components of a field and then compute
it okay don't bother to try to remember
the general formula just remember this
okay so what's the geometric
interpretation of curl just to finish
[Music]
[Applause]
so in a way I will say just curl
measures the rotation component in a
velocity field so an exercise that you
can do it's actually pretty easy to
check say that we have a fluid that's
just rotating about the z axis uniformly
okay so your fluid is just you know what
dating like that about the z axis so if
I take a rotation about the z axis
that's given by your velocity field with
components negative well at let's say at
velocity at angular velocity Omega that
will be negative Omega times y than
Omega X and zero and the curl of that
you can compute and you will find two
Omega times K so concretely this curl
gives you the angular velocity of the
rotation well with a factor of two but
it doesn't matter and the axis of
rotation it is the direction of the axis
of rotation it tells you what ating
about the vertical axis and in general
if you have a complicated motion some of
it might be you know there's a
translation and then within the
translation there's maybe expansion and
rotation and shearing and everything and
the curl will compute how much rotation
is taking place so it will tell you say
that you have you know a very small
solid say I don't know a ping-pong ball
in your flow and it's just like going
with a flow it tells you how it's going
to start rotating
that's what curl measures
okay so on Thursday we'll see Stokes
theorem which will be the last
ingredient before the next exam and then
on Friday we'll review Civ